is uh commissioner with us uh todd he is
he's uh larry scott pac-12 commissioner
joining us early uh good morning
commissioner
as of this morning where do we stand
with football in the fall
with pac-12 uh
we've had a lot of progress over the
last uh day or two especially with
public health officials in california
and oregon and uh this on the heels
of the deal we did with quiedell which
gives us access
to daily testing with rapid results
i think has brought us a long way so our
medical advisory committee
is much more comfortable with us going
forward and it looks like the hurdles
have been cleared in terms of
the public health authorities in the
states of california
and oregon so things are looking a lot
more promising so i've got a call today
with our presidents and chancellors
we're going to take stock of where we
are and see if we're comfortable with a
path forward
before january 1st which was what our
previous decision was and
we'll see if we can align with others in
college football still this fall
will there be a vote today when you talk
to these presidents
i'm not expecting a vote today i'm not
going to push for one today i mean this
has been a
rapidly developing series of events
yesterday was uh
pretty crazy from a call i got from
governor newsome in the morning to
meetings
uh folks morgan oregon state had with
their governor that day
so yeah we need to give folks that lead
our campuses a
chance to digest all this take into
account everything going on on their
campuses
but we also realize that if we're going
to move forward
this fall with football where we need a
six-week
ramp up for our student-athletes in
california they haven't been in a gym
they haven't been they haven't been on a
field so they need six weeks
and then there's basketball too which
the ncaa just decided
on wednesday is going to start november
25th so we we've got to
figure out with both those are we come
from moving forward what i was told
yesterday and you
obviously can uh correct me if you need
to that if you're looking at a date
it'd be probably around halloween that
the first game in the
pac-12 so if we're going to move forward
it depends on how quickly
uh we can get back uh to practice you
know
six weeks would be from monday but we're
only getting these uh
rapid tests next week so i think that
would be the most ambitious
maybe maybe a week or two too quick for
us but some somewhere in that zip code
is where we'd be playing if we're
playing
but also it it's going to preclude you i
think from being
qualifying for the uh playoff
the final four right well uh if we were
to play
uh this fall i don't think anyone could
predict i was i was on the call of my
fellow commissioners
and uh you know we've got a board of the
college football playoff
i don't think if you ask any of my
fellow commissioners they can tell you
how many games their teams are going to
play
they know what they're going to try to
play but we've already seen in the first
two weeks every league that's tried to
play
has had to postpone games so no one's
feeling supremely confident
at this point especially those that
don't have daily tests
that their all their team's gonna play
every game so i think uh you know it's
uncharted territory
we don't know how many games each um
league's gonna play they're gonna be
many more differences than we're
normally used to and i don't know
you know whether the average is gonna be
six games or eight games i don't think
anyone can tell you we don't know what
player availability is going to be
and the committee is going to have the
work cut out from there's gonna be a lot
more subjectivity this year than the
best i would not rule anything out
so more likely to play in the fall than
the spring because last time we had john
a couple of weeks ago you said you know
we're we're targeting the spring
or right after uh you know january more
likely fall football than spring
football
i'd say at this stage uh it's promising
you know we've um
it's amazing how much has happened in
the last five weeks since we made our
decision
and the good news is you know we got
access to the kind of testing our
medical
folks required sooner than we thought
we've gotten public health authority
approval uh uh you know quickly earlier
than we thought and so we've tried
we've tried to do a couple of things
then and i've appreciated the chance to
talk here we've tried to be transparent
about what we're doing deliberate health
and safety first
but at the same time our student
athletes want to play and our coach want
to play our fans want to play so
we've been committed to explore every
possibility to do so when
we felt it was safe and we had
appropriate approval so
we're trying to be nimble and flexible
too and uh uh you know our president's
chancellors have been that too and
that's why they're convening on a call
real time to address this new
information and yeah if we if we can
provide an opportunity for our student
athletes to play
as soon as it's safe they won't apply
and we owe them that
if we can do it you think you'll know by
monday if you're playing
i think we have to decide you know by
next week um
if we're moving forward do you have a
target date not yet
no i you know i need to this has been a
rapidly escalating series of events over
the last 24 hours
and um i need to see where my presence
of chancellors are which i'll know later
today but what
changed is it just the rapid testing
like
the approval of the governors of oregon
and california
for for us the game changer was
being the first conference to get access
to daily testing and those tests are
being shipped to us on monday
with the machines and the readers and
the reason for that
is our medical advisors you know that
concerns about heart
the prevalence of the spread of the
virus and
they uh didn't feel comfortable playing
the sport of football or basketball for
that matter
if they thought you know the practice or
the games could lead to the spread
of device beyond what people might get
in their communities
or at the dining halls or in their dorms
or whatever the act of playing football
or basketball couldn't lead to the
spread and
uh getting access to daily testing gives
a high degree of confidence that's not
gonna happen so that was the game
changer for us
and i think it was a game changer for
the public health officials
which was the second major thing that
just happened
uh you know within the last 24 36 hours
is it everybody has to play or nobody
plays in the pac-12
um up till now uh we've been completely
unified in our approach and i expect
that will continue to be the case
last time we talked and i i'm
paraphrasing uh
but it felt like you were saying that
the big 12 and the acc and scc were
being a little more reckless
you were being very overly cautious and
so was the big ten
do you still feel that way well i doubt
i ever used the word reckless uh with
with my peers
um they um i mean that's why i was
paraphrasing there but you
you were you were you sent a message
there whether you
intended to or not fair enough i think
what i was trying to suggest is we have
been more cautious
um and i think you know the values in
every part of the country
are a little bit different the
priorities
and the pressures that people feel and i
think our league and is something i'm
proud of with our schools
have wanted to air if they were going to
err on the side of safety
the health and safety and welfare of the
student athletes even if it would come
at a significant cost
tv revenue attendance uh
etc and people want to play um and we
drew the line in the sand we weren't
going to do it
unless our medical advisors were very
confident and comfortable
and of course we need public health
authority approvals and different
leagues made different decisions but
i you know i've tried to be careful not
to cast judgment
on anyone else's decision-making i just
like to talk about the values we
we've had which have been more
conservative and cautious i think on our
show
before we talked about that's a
microcosm of what's going on in society
too yeah
yeah but you know i'm just trying to
figure this out with your role
when you get the presidents on the phone
do you advise them
like do you say this is what i want to
do or is it
you guys tell me what you want to do um
you know it's a it's a combination of
those things you know um
my job is to reflect and carry out what
our 12 schools ultimately want to do but
they rely on me
to uh you know do the legwork uh
bring them the facts and make a
recommendation that's what i'll do
and your recommendation is to play
football in the fall
oh they're going to hear my
recommendation first
your recommendation is to play football
in the fall we we we've overcome
the major obstacles that that we had and
the criteria that our medical advisors
set
uh with the public health authority
approvals and now but you know our
president's chances have to weigh
uh the issues on their campuses they'll
be the ultimate decision makers but in
terms of the metrics and the issues we
talked about
in mid-august the reasons why we weren't
going forward
we've made tremendous progress and have
overcome those things and normally i'll
report them that we've achieved those
things and and then it's up to them to
weigh it all and decide
and normally you would want to know what
the vote's going to be before you take
the vote but what you're saying is if
there is
a chancellor president who says look i
just don't feel comfortable doing that
can they sit out this football season
and the pac-12
continues to play with everybody else
we've never done that and i don't know
if we would do that
or not up until now so you think you can
get a consensus vote
i we've had a consensus at every step of
the way
i expect we're gonna have a consensus on
this
good luck uh and uh you know i i always
appreciate you coming on
i know it may feel like a firing squad
at times but i
my job is to get answers it's a very
important issue and
uh i know it's it's fluid it's day to
day almost hour to hour of trying to get
this done
and i wish you luck i appreciate it then
thank you
that's uh larry scott commissioner of
the pac-12